that matrons back I'm sorry he's not  after you why would he be my firm has  faced off in a fiery fit of the Lazarus  train yeah look he knows the crime-scene  photos that all they showed us  paramedics and writing symbols and blood  whoever is out there now is a complete  monster a monster that we're going to  catch I don't know anymore  lately I can't seem to win for losing  what do you mean we cut John's brother  high I ran in to damian darhk-- and he  tried to use his creepy magic mojo on me  but after that my my bloodlust was  better he was almost completely gone I  don't know I'm really just thought I was  starting to get on the other side of  this hey sounds like you already are now  matrons out there and he has a blood  lust of his own and it's completely my  fault no Thea you can't think that way  it's not too late for that  Eero all new tonight at 8 7 central of a  CW